[Music]
taylor finish your homework last night
yup
hello richard i know the truth about you
who you really are nero
tyler where's my son look at your screen
amigo
you follow my instructions today or he
will die
i need you for a job this vest is a
micro camera
everything you see i will see amigo
if you so not just touch the hair on my
kid's head i swear
down meeting going on the restaurant
kill every person there
and that's the only way you're gonna see
your son again alive i can't just go in
there
shooting up the place what about the
innocent bystanders there are no good
people in there
no saints only sinners
[Music]
bravo nero let's see if you can do some
more this is to a new beginning
and watching the utter destruction of
our enemies
why did he call you nero it's a name
from the past
i used to work for special forces i'm
sorry you got mixed up in all this
and this is how it's gonna end for you
if he survives this you'll come for us
are you scared
you better help and you should be too
[Music]
[Music]
you